I have about 4,000 dollars right there.
Ever heard of someone accidentally finding an object worth thousands of dollars?
Usually, it's either artwork or antiques.
But how about whale vomit?
While at a headland in Dorset, England, a school-age boy, Charlie Naysmith,...
...found a piece of whale vomit that may have a value of 40,000 British pounds.
Whale vomit is high in demand for its use in creating perfumes.
It is rare to see on the shore, as it could remain in the sea for decades.
The young boy is trying to decide what to do with the whale vomit,...
...but if it is sold, he would like to build a home designated for animals with the proceeds.
It is not the first time that a whale vomit discovery made news.
Several years ago, an Australian couple stumbled across a large piece.
The couple initially left the lump on the beach,...
...but weeks later, they saw it again, so they took it home.
The lump, weighing 14.75 kilograms, was estimated to have a value of 295,000 dollars.